[Music]
all right i've got the seed
what's the seeding rate how deep do i
need to plant this
there's a lot of questions around how to
plant cover crop seeds so this one i do
want to spend a
decent amount of time on so maybe we'll
just piece this up but
um how do you find the seeding rate or
the bushel weight on the cover crop seed
that we send out
hey you want me to handle that keith or
well i'll handle that first part there
when you get
and i don't know i'll throw one out and
hold it up here as dale's talking but
when you get the seat analysis sheet
it's going to save the seating rate
right on there
and and that will tell you 30 pounds an
acre 40 pounds an acre
and if you can't find that all you got
to do is
is take the number of acres that you're
doing the number of pounds of seed that
you have and just do the math
and you'll be able to tell very quickly
what your seeding rate needs to be
setting the drill is going to be a
little bit different deal
we are working on and probably won't be
this year but next year
um on those analysis reports it's going
to tell you what the bushel weight of
your overall
mix is going to be and again that's not
going to tell you how to set your drill
but it's going to be one
factor involved in helping you get close
and get started so
that's what we're printing out and
providing on the papers that we send you
and then once you get that then you have
to actually get that applied to your
drill so dale go ahead and talk about
several different ways that
the customer can do that yeah i mean
obviously there's
there's no drill setting for uh
you know a mixture of oats
peas veg radishes uh you know
there just isn't one and so a lot of
people are confused
well how do i set my grill well um
box grills meter out seed not
based on weight but on volume and the
way we
you know the the english system and that
and american agriculture
of measuring volume is in bushels so
it becomes important to determine what
is your bushel weight well one way of
doing that
um is to have one of these handy dandy
little bushel weight
apparatus and you know
you put seed in here and then you just
move this little
balance and it'll tell you your your
bushel weight
and then you basically find something
you know similar on your chart
of that bushel weight and set your drill
that way
and another way of doing it is to
mathematically
calculate go ahead no how much are those
i mean where do you get those
i we sell them but how do people get a
hold of those
well i said yeah you said it we sell
them so
how much are they
they're like 65 so they're you know
they're they're
a nice investment because you can use
those for planting wheat or
oats or peas they'll work for anything
and they're really easy to use
uh they're made out of plastic they're
fairly tough but
i mean don't run over them so you know
if you have a toolbox
or something on your drill we we just
carry we have a big plastic toolbox
bolted on the back of our drill and and
that just rides back there all the time
and it'll hold up for many many years if
as long as you're not
stepping on it or dropping it stuff like
that so 65 bucks
uh you just have to request it and we
can send it out with the seed
yeah you can also uh kind of do a
mathematical
calculation of about what your bushel
weight
is and noah can i share my screen i can
kind of run
through i put about six seven slides
together that kind of
through the process
uh
okay so basically i i just put
an example here of an op blend
and so you want to convert this to
bushels
so let's just say we have a mix it's 94
pounds of seed per acre
64 pounds of oats and 30 pounds of peas
how do you set the drill so let's go
through the procedure
so we want to convert that into bushels
because drills don't plant pounds
they plant bushels they plant a certain
volume
when you set them so oats are 32 pounds
of bushel
so the 64 pounds of oats is two bushels
the peas are 60 pounds of bushels so 30
pounds
is half bushel so the is
two total a half bushels and so you just
set the drill to the approximate
number of bushels uh two and a half
bushels would be
80 pounds of oats or 150 pounds of peas
two and a half times 32 is 80
for the oats two and a half times 60 is
obviously two completely different
numbers but if you do
both those settings you'll find out
they're
almost exactly the same drill setting
even though they're dramatically
different numbers
because of the density the but the
completely different busheling
now i want to stress this does not
replace calibration
and so i'll go through a quick
calibration procedure
for a box drill and the things you need
something to catch the seed in scales
and of course
the drill and a means of raising the
drill
up if you've got a pole type drill um
you'll want to have some jacks a couple
jacks to raise it up
so that you can spin the drive wheel
freely
and so here's your procedure um put the
seed in the drill
measure the circumference of your
driveway i i probably should have put a
a tape measure measuring tape on there
as well
whatever your drive will if it's an end
wheel or you know
measure that driveway the distance
around it
then raise the drill off the ground
whether it's three-point
or jacks uh whatever it takes to get
that drill off the ground so you can
spin the drive wheel
place the tarp underneath the drill
in the drive wheel i like to do it a
hundred times because it makes the math
easier
um weigh the seed that's in the tarp
[Music]
and then you just do the math
your pounds per acre is you just plug it
into this equation
your pounds collected on the tarp and
the
area is going to be your drill width
that's a
10 foot drill 30 foot drill times your
tire circumference
your length your width is of course the
drill width
and the length that you travel during
that calibration is going to be
your tire circumference times the number
of times you spun
and there's 43 560 square feet of an
acre
so you just convert that
area that you planted
to acres and that gives you your pounds
break
so if if anybody you know that this is
going to be
posted um so you can
review this later if you need to yeah
and i'll note too
dale and i have a plan here we're going
to try and get a drill calibration video
made so that it'll be more in depth and
we'll actually probably do that on our
drill so that
you'll be able to see that and dale very
likely probably just sold about 50 of
those little drill calibrators
because if you want to want to go do all
that math just by submit 65 bucks
and yeah for those little deals it's
really quick and simple to use
yeah and and uh i i used to teach math
and people say well
i'll just pay somebody to do this for me
in the future
that's that's what you're doing right
there that that's what we're doing right
there
so yeah um i i found that
nobody has time to calibrate a drill
but everybody has time to drive 400
miles to get
two more bags of seed
yes so it's better to calibrate
than to run out and be scrambling and
scraping for seed later
it's on the paper and when you get your
especially if you're getting a tote bag
if we are shipping that and you look in
the little plastic holder on the tote
it's going to have your address the
shipping label in there you have to look
behind
it to get the seed analysis sheet and
that's where the pounds per acre and
eventually the bushel wait for
for the overall mix is going to be as
well
most of those bags do not have multiple
plastic holders
so we have to put both those pieces of
paper in that one little
ziploc bag holder thing on the toe
[Music]
you